die rätselhafte lungenkrankheit in china
hat mittlerweile sechs todesopfer
gefordert auch die infizierten zahl
steigt auf mittlerweile fast 300 die
experten wissen zwar inzwischen dass
sich das neuartige virus auch von mensch
zu mensch überträgt trotzdem gibt es
noch viele fragezeichen
die weltgesundheitsbehörde will morgen
bei einem krisentreffen überprüfen ob
eine internationale notlage ausgerufen
werden soll so viele schutzmasken sieht
man in china sonst nur wenn die
luftwerte schlecht sind
diesmal ist es der schutz vor dem
scheinbar ansteckende neuen corona virus
am hauptbahnhof in shanghai reisen die
menschen zum neujahrsfest mit einem
mulmigen gefühl denn seit zwei tagen ist
die zahl der infizierten stark gestiegen
natürlich habe ich angst und dieses
virus kann sich auf einmal weiter
ausbreiten und wenn sich das virus
während des neujahrsfest ausbreitet wird
das eine schreckliche epidemie werden
ich bin nicht zuversichtlich ich weiß
nicht ob man den frauen kommen was man
uns erzählt ich glaube dass die zahl der
infizierten viel höher ist als man uns
weismachen
zumindest werden immer mehr
verdachtsfälle auch im ausland gemeldet
in korea in hongkong japan australien
überall werden kontrollen verstärkt der
ursprung aller infizierten mit der
seltenen lungenkrankheit liegt wohl in
der elf millionen stadt wuhan in
zentralchina
dort sind auch viele ärzte und
krankenpfleger an dem virus erkrankt und
doch versuchen die menschen hier ihr
normales leben zu leben so weit es geht
die marktszene ist typisch für die
stimmung in der stadt die menschen gehen
ihren täglichen geschäften nachkaufen
fisch und fleisch natürlich gibt es mehr
sorge vor allem weil die zahl der
erkrankungen so dramatisch schnell in
den letzten tagen angestiegen ist auch
wenn die menschen ihre schutzmasken
tragen und panik lässt der alltag nicht
zu und china ist hin und hergerissen
zwischen dem wunsch dass es schon nicht
so schlimm sein wird und immer mehr
steigenden zahlen von toten infizierten
und verdachtsfälle